todo
[Música]
hola hoy en saint es click es posible ir
más rápido que la luz
se dice con frecuencia que la expansión
del universo hace de algunos objetos más
rápido que la luz misma
ciertamente la distancia que separa
algunos cuerpos celestes puede aumentar
más rápido que la velocidad de la luz
pero esto se debe a la expansión del
universo en sí o gráficamente de la
cuadrícula subyacente sobre la que se
sitúan todas las entidades esta
cuadrícula está en constante expansión
por lo que la distancia de los objetos
crece constantemente
en realidad esto no es un movimiento
verdadero pues nos permite transmitir
información más rápido que la luz
a excepción de la expansión del universo
es posible que algo se mueva más rápido
que la luz en el espacio
la teoría de la relatividad especial nos
enseña que la velocidad de un objeto
modifica el transcurso de ese tiempo
propio entre más rápido se mueva con
respecto al observador más se hace lento
su tiempo en comparación con el del
observador
si este objeto llevase un reloj el
tiempo que tardarían sus manecillas sin
completar una vuelta sería mayor que de
un reloj idéntico sin movimiento
cuanto más rápido se mueva un objeto en
el espacio más lento se mueve en el
tiempo
para cuantificar esta situación
dibujemos un gráfico muy sencillo que
represente el transcurso del tiempo en
función de la velocidad de un objeto
para un objeto quieto con velocidad nula
el tiempo transcurre a su ritmo normal
en cambio por el objeto viajando al 100%
de la velocidad de la luz el tiempo
simplemente se detendría transcurriría a
una velocidad de 0
se podría pensar que si el tiempo se
detiene a la velocidad de la luz para un
objeto viajando aún más rápido sería
posible retroceder en el tiempo
entre más superamos la velocidad de la
luz más retrocederíamos hacia el pasado
con un paso del tiempo negativo
es una idea que parece plausible e
incluso muy atractiva
sin embargo esto se basa en una
suposición implícita ilustrada por la
unión de dos puntos con una línea recta
[Música]
es cierto que existe una curva que los
une y sobre la que se sitúan todos los
objetos del universo
cualquier forma de materia cualquier
objeto se sitúa sobre esta curva y a
medida que se mueve a una cierta
velocidad su tiempo propio transcurre a
un ritmo determinado
así el tiempo se frena de la misma
manera para todos los objetos dado que
tienen la misma velocidad
[Música]
cuando esta curva se obtiene
experimentalmente descubrimos que para
un objeto que se mueve el 50% de la
velocidad de la luz su tiempo propio
transcurre no al 50% sino al 87% del
ritmo habitual
del mismo modo si un objeto se mueve un
80% de la velocidad de la luz su tiempo
propio transcurre al 60% del valor
ordinario para una velocidad del 25 por
ciento de la de la luz no vemos casi
ninguna diferencia ya que el tiempo
correspondiente transcurre a un 97 por
ciento de lo habitual
la curva que aparece ante nuestros ojos
resulta no ser una línea recta sino un
cuarto de círculo cualquier tipo de
materia contenida en el universo puede
así situarse en algún punto de este
cuarto de círculo
esta curva puede extenderse hasta formar
un círculo completo
a la izquierda del gráfico las
velocidades negativas corresponden a las
velocidades alcanzadas al moverse en
sentido opuesto
sin moverse hacia la derecha da una
velocidad positiva de un kilómetro por
hora por ejemplo moverse con una
velocidad negativa de -1 kilómetros por
hora equivale simplemente a moverse con
esa velocidad hacia la izquierda
pero para empezar vemos que no es
posible ir más rápido que la velocidad
de la luz ni ir por encima del 100% del
transcurrir del tiempo del observador a
un parón hipotético objeto que
retrocediera en el tiempo con un
transcurso temporal negativo sigue
siendo estrictamente imposible ir más
allá de la velocidad de la luz porque
todos los objetos están confinados en
este círculo
la cuestión no es entonces saber si es
posible ir más allá de la velocidad de
la luz sino entender por qué ello es
imposible porque nuestra curva tiene
forma de círculo y qué tiene de especial
esta velocidad de la luz
comencemos por observar la forma
particular de esta curva un círculo una
de las propiedades claves de un círculo
es que todos los puntos que lo componen
están situados a igual distancia de su
centro para cualquier objeto la única
medida significativa no es la velocidad
que se mueve ni la cadencia de su tiempo
sino la distancia al centro del gráfico
esta forma de medir toma en cuenta tanto
el movimiento del objeto en el espacio
como su movimiento en el tiempo
es de alguna manera la unificación de
las dos velocidades
unimos tanto en movimiento del objeto en
el espacio como en el tiempo esto es lo
que llamamos la velocidad en el
espacio-tiempo
[Música]
sea cual sea la velocidad de un objeto
tanto se acelera como si frena su
posición en el gráfico cambiará pero su
distancia al centro siempre será la
misma
esta medida es una constante fundamental
universal que rige sobre todas las
entidades del universo la llamamos la
velocidad de la luz es importante
entender que la velocidad de la luz
tiene un carácter fundamental su
importancia no proviene del hecho de que
sea la velocidad a la que viaja la luz
pero sí del hecho de que en el
espacio-tiempo cuando consideramos tanto
el espacio como el tiempo es la
velocidad a la que se mueven todos los
objetos del universo
con esto en mente entendemos mejor el
fenómeno en juego
los objetos no pueden ir más allá de la
velocidad de la luz porque efectivamente
se mueven con esa velocidad concreta en
cualquier circunstancia lo único que
puede cambiar es la forma en que la
velocidad de un objeto se distribuye en
el espacio y el tiempo si el objeto está
más bien arriba en el gráfico la gran
parte de su velocidad al tiempo y muy
poca el espacio su tiempo transcurre
casi normalmente pero se mueve
lentamente en el espacio este es el tipo
de comportamiento que presentan los
objetos de nuestra vida cotidiana que se
mueven muy lentamente en comparación con
la velocidad de la luz
en cambio si el objeto se encuentra más
hacia la esquina inferior derecha del
gráfico se de más de su velocidad del
espacio que al tiempo
así los objetos del universo que más
rápido vemos mover lo hacen lentamente
en el tiempo en cámara lenta en
comparación con nosotros
este es el caso de la luz en particular
que se de toda su velocidad del espacio
sin dejar ninguna al tiempo una
partícula de luz se mueve extremadamente
rápido pero su tiempo propio no
transcurre en absoluto si una partícula
de luz llevase consigo un reloj
hipotético las agujas de ese reloj ni
siquiera se movería
un objeto que acelera no aumenta su
velocidad solo convierte su velocidad
temporal la que le permite desplazarse
en el tiempo en velocidad espacial que
le permite desplazarse en el espacio y
viceversa un objeto que frena convierte
una parte de su velocidad espacial en
velocidad temporal se desacelera en el
espacio y en consecuencia acelera en el
tiempo el valor total de su velocidad en
el espacio-tiempo se mantiene constante
sigue moviéndose a la velocidad de la
luz lo único que ha cambiado es la
distribución de esa velocidad en el
espacio y el tiempo para terminar esta
representación en forma de gráfico tiene
muchas ventajas ya que es muy llamativa
visualmente y nos permite intuir ciertos
fenómenos
por ejemplo podemos preguntarnos si
existen o no objetos en la parte
inferior del gráfico intuitivamente
tales objetos estarían retrocediendo en
el tiempo ya que su velocidad temporal
sería negativa siguiendo este
razonamiento podríamos postular que
existen un tipo específico de partículas
que se situarían en esta parte del
diagrama
es lo que comúnmente se conoce como
antimateria
las partículas de antimateria tienen
propiedades idénticas a las partículas
ordinarias solo que su carga eléctrica
está invertida son simétricas a las
partículas ordinarias en la parte
superior del gráfico se encuentra la
materia ordinaria mientras que en la
parte inferior su reflejo la antimateria
en cuanto a las partículas de luz
también conocidas como fotones son su
propio reflejo simétrico al estar en el
eje horizontal son a la vez partículas y
antipartículas
sin embargo es importante ser cautelosos
ya que toda esta representación se basa
únicamente en el modelo de la
relatividad especial que solo es válido
en un universo vacío y perfectamente
plano
en realidad nuestro universo no es plano
está lleno de estrellas y planetas que
distorsionan en cuatro dimensiones la
geometría del espacio-tiempo
bajo estas condiciones debemos recurrir
a la teoría de la relatividad general
en la relatividad general la gravedad no
existe es la curvatura del
espacio-tiempo la que convierte la
velocidad temporal de un objeto en una
velocidad espacial
de una manzana originalmente el reposo
cae de un árbol es porque su evolución
en el tiempo se convirtió gradualmente
en una evolución en el espacio es decir
en una velocidad como resultado de la
curvatura del espacio-tiempo debida a la
tierra
si observamos desde lejos un objeto
situado junto a una entidad masiva como
la tierra
la gráfica asociada es objeto comenzará
a distorsionar se junto a un agujero
negro el círculo se distorsiona tanto
que se hace cada vez más pequeño a
medida que el objeto se acerca a su
horizonte cuando el objeto alcanza el
horizonte de sucesos el círculo se ha
contraído por completo esto significa
que el objeto no le queda margen de
movimiento desde nuestro punto de vista
permanece inmóvil en reposo sobre la
superficie del agujero negro
cuando los observamos desde lejos todos
los objetos que caen en un agujero negro
terminan por aparecer pegados a su
superficie pero para el objeto en sí
este fenómeno es sólo una ilusión desde
su punto de vista es posible atravesar
el horizonte del agujero negro y seguir
cayendo gradualmente hacia la
singularidad central
sin embargo visto desde el exterior
toda la información contenida por este
objeto se hace más lenta hasta llegar a
una parada final y permanecer fija sobre
la superficie del agujero negro
una de las consecuencias más importantes
de este fenómeno es que la entropía de
un agujero negro es decir algo así como
su información y su temperatura se
reparte por completo a lo largo de su
superficie
[Música]